joining us back here on the show the now
perennial Pro Bowl wide receiver of the
charge was Keenan Allen how are you
Keenan great how you I'm doing better
for talking to you before we start
talking about you your former teammate
tyro williams balled out last night i
wonder if he caught any of that in
Oakland yes sir what do you think of
that uh you know he could do it that's
that's the potential he had he's a great
player too glad they can getting the
ball and let my boy work so I mean what
can you I don't know really know much
about him I mean what do you think that
meant to him to be able to on Monday
Night Football be in this spot that now
he's suddenly thrust in is a number one
receiver that the whole team is counting
on Keenan yeah I think that was
basically he's big on confidence
he's got me who meets confidence that's
like you know once you get it he's a
he's what he was last night unstoppable
and he's and he's open uh he's fast they
need to make plays after oh we keep that
confidence so what did you think of
again your ear is a good receivers or is
the National Football League Keenan and
again I know it's somebody else's house
but it is some team that is in your
division the Antonio Brown departure
from Oakland now showing up in New
England what do you think about that
[Music]
thing going on over here
right well yeah you got your own thing
going on over there and so week number
one for the Chargers coming out as you
guys did what what does that mean for
your team's confidence Keenan Allen
I think was big be sure that we that we
are a good team coming off the last year
we had a great offseason oth training
camp and then to come out and put it
together week one first half first that
was great second half was not not too
shabby but you know we clean it up and
I'm you know we came out with the win so
take it any way you get it okay and and
the fact that again you had a team in
Indianapolis that is resilient as it was
last year or what do you think that
proves for your team moving forward here
so do we play well together it was a
great team win everybody did their job
some mishaps here and there you know the
other phases but uh you know like I said
we clean it up watch the film you know I
think this guy too limited for the team
so and the fact that you won in overtime
what was it like in the locker room
after the game to us in there Keenan I
was big obviously we didn't we didn't
want to be in that situation
I don't we had to leave but uh you know
in a situation we obviously want to come
out victorious and I think we did a
great job you know is in our hands
offensive hands and you know before we
went on a field we said it uh you know
that's going in it again what's it like
being right now what's it like being in
the huddle with Phillip in a situation
like that is easy his composure is is
amazing um you know just was like
practice like we're doing the two-minute
drill or something huh I got to have a
period or something um you know we just
come in there and it's the same the
first quarter pretty much what do you
mean by that
just chill you know he's not we're not
panicking
with this Colin place with his run in
our house trying to execute the same way
we doing the first quarter so so it's
just because he's such an old hand at it
is it his demeanor I mean like I said I
mean yeah his demeanor uh the way he the
way he comes in as he takes over no like
I say you you don't even know what
quarter it is so you never can tell when
when the pressures on
and how does that affect your ability to
ball out of them guys made it
but he's calling the play so when he
called the play with confidence I'm like
okay he think it's my work I think it's
more
so that's that's the way it goes
you're such a mild-mannered guy when you
call here on the show Keenan Allen but I
see a lot of woofin out there on the
field what's uh where does that come
from
copy desert the confidence me putting
them to work going out there having
successfully you know sewing up a sort
of game you know just laying it all out
on the field um you know I like I like
let my defenders know know what's going
on to them what can you give me a slight
example of what of what it sounds like
if it's safe for work you mean your best
safe for work example rarely do I not
cut so it's the anti Phillip then it's
the anti fellow yeah anti anti okay so
you're basically but so does that hype
you I mean like could you do it without
that or that's just always been part of
your game Keenan I think he's always
been part of my game um just that like I
said it's being passionate feels the
same way he just doesn't cuz you know
it's just being so passionate about the
game having success even when we're not
having success you know yelling at the
referee stuff like that sure that's
Keenan Allen here a couple more minutes
left with the sharp Chargers wide
receiver when was the last time you
spoke to Melvin Gordon Keenan yesterday
okay how's he doing
nice alright obviously wants to be
playing obviously wants a home once the
team but uh you know it is what it is at
this point you know you know China stay
ready okay so do you reach out did you
reach out to him him reach out to you
I'm wondering how that
okay he's reaching out to you and and
that's your method of communication all
that said obviously you love the guy and
you want him out there but then you see
someone like Austin Eckler and and
Jackson do it just in Jackson do what he
does with his opportunity what what does
that mean to you the same thing I mean I
think I was not saying it all along
those guys of all
yeah I don't think it was no secret you
know to it all they got in they make
play just just like they did last year
and they look for that well necklace and
um they you've seen it when he came in
last year Pittsburgh so they there's
great athletes making plays you know you
know I don't think it would change
anything about um for the situation
they're in but like I say we live at
that okay
Keenan Allen couple more minutes left
again with him is it true you originally
committed to Alabama or going to count
is that a fact
you know yes sir free safety number one
in the nation what happened walk me
through this year I need I needed the
ball first started like I said I was
number one and they sent free safety so
I went to army all-american game uh-huh
played safety the whole game had one
punt returns all the time I touched the
ball and I was just married but it was
just born and felt like I could be more
involved more impact on the game I was
on offering so and then my brother was
that Buffalo when you transfer turner
field transfer went to Kansas and he
went to my brother with the cow so I
decided to go to cat with him like
offense no no you know here we are
so is it Saban who recruited you were
you recruited by Nicky saving yeah
uh-huh
did you tell were you the one who
informed Nick that you needed a ball in
your hands and I'm not coming okay at
the time I bet who is the one who
changed your position a wide receiver
then I mean well I'd already play see
right I would just ranked as a free
safety um I think I probably play
receiver at Alabama as well right well
let's be honest here keen and your hands
are way too good to be a safety right
yeah I mean you know with unrespected
Erwin James hopefully the best of both
world it said they're just way too
talented too big Malik hook by the way
that was a that was a ridiculous pick
the other day
when you add Hulu I was with that I was
insane great first game keen and great
start and certainly you need to keep it
going you're in the division with three
teams that won this past weekend looks
like the AFC West is going to be as
competitive as many people think it is
so I appreciate you taking the time here
on an off day and give me a ring yeah I
appreciate you right back at you Keenan
Allen thanks again that's Keenan Allen
at Keenan 13 Allen to follow him on
Twitter for more of the Rich Eisen show
tune - audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
for free on BR live or download the Rich
Eisen show app